Yes, Festival Week, this is where I
come into my own. I love a good
festival.
I mean, it's not really Sandi's cup
of tea.
Noel? Noel? Noel?
What you doing in there?
Are we there yet?
I thought the bag felt heavy,
I thought it was all the food I'd
packed. No, I've eaten that.
I did, however, bring blueberries.
Why would you bring blueberries?
It's a festival, I thought
there might be a jam session.
Oh, no!
Can you not mention blueberries
when we're backstage?
You'll ruin my cool reputation.
Oh, too late.
Last time, it was Dessert Week.
New territory - again!
And Steph was crowned Star Baker
for the third week in a row.
That's one of the best things I've
had to eat for a long time.
Yeah!
Oh... what?!
A close race... I'm coming behind
you, Priya, coming behind you.
..left Henry thinking his time
in the tent was up.
I've spent the past hour
prepping my little goodbyes.
But it was Priya...
The colour of the blueberry
cream is horrible.
..who said her goodbyes.
Aww!
This week... Yes!
..it's celebratory baking.
Don't look.
With festive
buns from around the world.
What are you doing?
My balls are out on the table!
Sicilian party
pastries in the Technical...
No-one ever thought I'd need to
sieve some cheese.
..and a colourful Showstopper...
I don't know what temperature
to have it at. ..with layer...
Burning, burning, burning.
..upon layer of pressure.
Not good. What?
This is a disaster, isn't it?
I didn't think I'd make week one,
never mind week seven.
I'm glad I got
Star Baker before the rise of Steph.
The fact that I've been
Star Baker three times -
it's pressure, but you're forever
just on to the next thing.
I haven't practised as much as I'd
have liked to.
I had to mark 180 exam papers
and I've written 150 reports.
It's been a hard week!
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the
tent! It's Festival Week!
SANDI CHEERS
And for your Signature Challenge
today,
you're gonna be making festival
buns.
The judges would like 24 yeasted
festival buns.
They should be your version
of the celebrated breads
you might find at festivals,
such as Eid or Christmas,
Hanukkah, Diwali. Basically,
each bun must tell a story.
And that story is probably...
"Oh, no, someone with blue eyes
"has eaten me!" OK, no spoilers,
thank you, Noel. Sorry.
You've got three hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
Let the magic happen.
I've started activating my yeast.
Smells really yeasty.
Smells like a brewery.
The bakers have got to
produce 24 festival buns.
They can represent any
country in the world,
they can have pretty much
anything in, as long as
it's related to a festival.
But they've got to get them
beautifully light, airy, and full
of flavour, and pack a punch.
The most obvious festival bun to us
is the hot cross bun at Easter.
These buns have to be yeasted
but they could have spice in there
or other flavours. What I'm after is
uniform, beautifully flavoured,
beautifully textured,
absolutely delicious buns.
So I'm doing a take on a hot
cross bun.
Orange and lemon zest
and plenty of spice.
Eastertime...
Steph's festive buns will also be
filled with cranberries
and sultanas.
And when it comes to her flavours,
she's hoping to live up to her
triple-Star Baker status.
So this will be
the cinnamon going in.
I hope the spices come through
enough in it.
I've made
so many hot cross buns this week,
just to try and nail it, really.
Michael and Alice...
Come on, do your thing.
..are also attempting their own
spins on the Easter classic.
There's a few of us that have
gone for hot cross buns this week.
I mean, Easter, to me, it reminds me
of spending time with my
grandparents, just
kind of like springtime, baking,
and I thought, something a bit
fresh. Trying to put a
bit of a twist on it,
so I'm doing yeah,
lemon, blueberry
and almond hot cross buns.
Alice's buns will feature fresh
and freeze-dried blueberries,
and they'll be finished with
a lemon curd glaze.
You're glazing it with lemon curd?
Yes. How does that work, then?
So, quite like a... If I heat it up
and it's runny enough
to spread over the bun.
Is it gonna be sticky to hold?
Yeah. Which a good hot cross
bun should be, yeah. Yeah.
OK, that's interesting.
All right, good luck. Thank you.
Look forward to it, thank you.
Thank you.
Not content with just one
festive celebration,
Michael's buns are a hybrid of two.
I am making sticky pudding
hot cross buns.
So I'm pairing
the festival of Easter with the
festival of Christmas.
Michael's hot cross
between Christmas and Easter buns,
will be brushed
with a brandy glaze.
Served with
brandy butter,
and packed full
of dried fruit.
Tell us
your filling inside your dough.
So, I've got sultanas, cranberries,
dates, and apricots,
and they're soaking in some
brandy just now.
I thought figgy pudding
had figs in it.
Oh, yes, I've got figs in it
as well, sorry, forgot to say that!
LAUGHTER
So how much, in total,
are you putting in, fruit?
500g! To how much flour?
To 1kg of flour!
That's a lot of fruit.
A lot of fruit.
It's a lot of fruit. Is that right?
Is it wrong?
Good luck, anyway.
LAUGHTER
Thank you very much. Still,
at least he's left you
feeling confident. I think
that's the important thing
that's happened here. Good luck.
Thank you! Oh, I need it.
When it comes to
flavouring enriched dough...
The fruits that have gone in -
sultanas, cranberries,
and mixed peel...
..careful balance is required.
This is mixed spice, just to give it
a little bit of warmth.
As too much will inhibit the yeast.
In practice,
they once came out
and they were like bricks.
I'm just tight on time.
I need to get these proving.
Resulting in tight, dense buns.
These are raisins... I'm just trying
to make sure they get
nicely divided through the dough.
I am doing kozunak, which is
a Bulgarian Easter bread.
David is adding traditional lemon
and almonds to his
Easter bread plaits,
to honour
his close ties
with Bulgaria.
So, my older brother
and his wife live in Bulgaria.
And my partner comes from Bulgaria,
so Nick's helped me
a lot in kind of talking
about flavours,
but then also,
my sister-in-law in Bulgaria,
cos she bakes them. There's actual
competitions to see who
does the best kozunak.
Mine is gonna win.
Whilst David's celebrating
in Eastern Europe...
Get out, get out...
..Henry is heading north to Sweden.
I'm making chocolate
kardemummabullar.
Which is my favourite
word in the world.
And what's the festival?
Cinnamon Bun Day is October 4th.
What are they celebrating
on October 4th? Just the bun?
Just the existence of the bun
itself. The existence of the bun!
The existence of the bun.
Henry's swapping cinnamon for
cardamom, almond
and chocolate creme patisserie
to celebrate his Swedish buns.
And he'll be twisting them into
classic kardemummabullar shapes.
I can see this as being
your challenge,
Henry, Lord of the Buns!
Do you like festivals?
I've never been to a festival!
Love that about you!
Not even a book one.
I've been to a book festival!
This is now going to prove,
so probably for about 30 minutes.
Go to bed for a bit.
As their dough
goes in for its first prove...
So this will prove once like this
and then I'll prove it again when
they are in their bun shapes.
..the bakers must
move on to their festive fillings
and decorations.
I'm just worried about this
lemon peel.
It needs to hurry up cos it takes me
ages just to chop it
up into little pieces.
Rosie is ensuring her rich
buns will be oozing with even more
richness.
I'm making my namelaka.
Go back on namelaka. Namelaka.
Mm? It's a form of pastry cream
made from milk, double cream,
gelatine, lemon zest,
liquid glucose and white chocolate.
OK. Sounds good.
I'm looking forward to these.
So these are not rich buns at all.
No, there's no calories
in them at all, no, no!
LAUGHTER
Diet ones, yeah.
As well as her Japanese-inspired
lemon and white chocolate
namelaka,
Rosie's buns will be filled with
raspberry jam and elaborately
decorated to look like
Mardi Gras peacocks.
Festival peacocks.
Yeah, obviously! Wow.
It's a thing. You're a vet.
Have you ever worked on a peacock?
I've never treated a peacock.
A peacock with a migraine.
It'd be great to have a peacock,
wouldn't it?
And just... Take it for walks.
Yes, like a '70s pimp,
with a big collar. Mm.
Two peacocks. Please do this.
The thing about a mask,
it makes you completely anonymous.
Sorry, who are you?
I'm waiting for Sandi
to do a time call. Oh, sorry, Prue.
It's OK, Paul. Bakers,
you are halfway through.
It is working, just slowly.
If the bakers don't prove their
enriched dough for long enough...
It's not ready.
It's still bouncing back.
..they won't achieve the light,
airy buns
that Paul and Prue are expecting.
It helps if you watch it.
Has Paul gone? He's gone.
Not having Paul see me do this.
Under-proved dough will be too tight
and is likely to crack
when baked.
All right, that's ready.
But the bakers are only halfway to
achieving perfect, fluffy
festival buns.
What a lovely dough to work with.
Before they can
prove for a second time,
they need to shape
the dough into 24 identical buns.
It's really hard to get them
identical cos I twist them.
I can't get every twist the same.
I don't want any
kind of blueberries sticking up.
What are you doing?
Rubbing your buns?
My balls are out on the table!
Horrible doing the plaits.
It's cos I'm using a Paul Hollywood
technique that I looked up
on YouTube.
Is she still there?
I don't like it.
What are you doing? I'm having fun,
I'm twisting some buns.
You get the strip... Yeah...
Then I'm giving it,
like, a little core. Yep.
And the I'll just go... like that.
Wow.
You've blown my mind.
Which one looks the least good?
Cos I've got a spare.
I'd take that one out,
it doesn't look as even
as the others.
You're out, mate.
OK, Sandi, I'm just gonna put
you down here for a minute,
I'm gonna do a time call.
Bakers, you've got one hour left,
one hour remaining.
Is that OK?
Oh...
I'm gonna use clingfilm just to
keep it moist while it proves.
So they're just gonna stay
here for a moment.
Panicking? Just...
Breaking up? Yeah.
I've heard this on the grapevine
that you've been marking
exams! Oh, my God!
It's been the worst week!
Is it nice to get back in the tent,
then?
It's... Do you know what?
It's kind of a... break from marking.
Quite relaxing. Right, I'm so sorry.
I'm just gonna...
All right, well, good luck!
Got to make brandy glaze.
This is sugar syrup and spices.
I will just see that some flavour
has come into it.
Right, need to make my lemon curd.
That's just honey, maple syrup,
brown sugar, cardamom for
the glaze. It will be very strong.
I can't taste any cardamom.
More cardamom? More?
Nah, back in.
Hi!
Are these real peacock feathers?
Yeah. This makes me
so happy. We need a sort of
cape, though, as well, don't we?
Please wear it.
What, wear this for the judges?
Yeah. All right.
I'll wear it for you, yeah?
I can't work out
whether they're ready or not.
Mm, there's a couple of quite
wee ones in here.
Gonna egg-wash them...
Oh, wow, look at that egg.
This is just flour and water...
One's a bit squint,
but I'll call it a Saltire.
A Scottish one. Your nose
doesn't look right, you got a cold?
Hay fever. Oh, fair enough. Bakers,
you have half an hour, half an hour.
Right, they're going in.
They look all right,
they will be fine.
OK, we're gonna go in.
My heart's racing.
Going in -
200 degrees for about 18 minutes.
Right, 15 minutes...
They're cracked a wee
bit on the top. I think mine might
have been a little bit under-proved.
Hide them.
Hide them at the bottom.
They're normally really dark
by this point, at home.
That's the best thing I've
ever done.
I'm just gonna give them
another... 49 seconds.
I feel like I want to go in
and get them.
Oh, they look baked!
Yeah, I'm gonna take them out.
About that sort of colour,
is what I'm aiming for.
OK...
I tried to keep them away
from each other, but some of them
have stuck, so I'll just put
the bad ones in the middle.
They are a bit messy,
but they'll do.
Bakers,
you've only got five minutes left...
Five, four... No, just...
Just five. Five.
Right, we're gonna glaze in the tin
cos we've not time
to do anything else.
The glaze, hopefully,
will give a bit of a kick,
but a lot of the brandy
evaporates off.
Some have exploded.
Let's hope they taste all right, eh?
I'm covering my cracks up
with some leaves.
Go, go, go.
Sugar, sugar, sugar.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please, take your buns and place
them at the end of your stations.
I really want to eat one of yours.
SANDI: Paul and Prue will now decide
if our bakers' festive
buns are worth celebrating.
Hello, David. Hello. Hi, David.
I think the plaiting and the
shaping look very, very good.
Very good.
Couple of minutes less, perhaps.
It's just gone a little bit
dark there.
Mmm.
I don't think they're bad at all.
The shapes are amazing.
They look really good, I think.
It's nice texture there.
It's, um...
Springs softly. Mmm.
I love the flavour of saffron. It's
really good with the sugar on top.
That's a well baked dough.
The structure's good, the flavour is
fantastic. It just needs that...
..a few extra little
bits of fruit in there. Mmm.
Very good, though. I'm impressed.
Well done.
They are a bit uneven,
aren't they? Yeah.
They will be slightly misshapen
because of the volume
of fruit in there as well,
because you get one with more
fruit in it, it can't grow as much
as one that has got less fruit in.
But they're lovely and shiny
and I like the glaze.
Yeah, the glaze looks good.
The decoration's nice.
It's a little tough, actually.
But I think your flavour is spot-on.
The spaces are nicely warming
and balanced with the fruit.
It's very good.
It does taste like figgy pudding.
It's really delicious.
I do think they look very shiny
and very attractive,
and my mouth's watering.
They smell amazing, don't they?
Let's have a look.
The fruit distribution's in there,
actually,
and we didn't see it down
the middle, but you can actually
see it properly in two halves
when you cut it down the middle.
The texture's perfect.
The texture is lovely.
Yeah, and they're sticky.
I can feel it on the fingers.
It's not too much spice,
and it's not too little. Mmm.
Well done. Well done, Steph.
Well done, Steph.
They're nice hot cross buns, them.
Yes!
I think they all look similar
to each other.
There's a bit more of a difference
in the colours. Even side to side.
Wow. Well, you've got your
blueberries in the middle. Yeah.
Nice texture.
Do you candy the lemon peel? Yes.
Took me quite a while.
Yeah, it needed a bit more.
Quite bitter, isn't it,
the lemon in there?
The sweetness hasn't come out in it.
I also think the lemon curd glaze
is not as attractive,
because it's not shiny enough.
Mmm.
I think you baked them well.
I just think there's a pretty
irregular colour going on in there.
Mmm. And size.
Well, they look home-made.
They're a lovely colour.
They look great.
Highly decorative.
I mean, they'd look
great in a shop window, those.
The buns themselves look
a bit flattish.
You can see they're sitting
quite squat.
I think you've got pretty
consistent on the colour.
And there's a bit of raspberry jam.
They're a nice flavour.
I look at that crumb...
Now, this is where you've dug it out
and you've put this in.
See how dense it is down there?
I did have to do it when it was
quite hot, so I was sort of
cutting them and then pressing down
with a fork when it was a bit hot.
So, it's condensed the dough
down at the bottom.
It's really pleasant. It's like...
sort of almost doughnut texture.
It's nice.
I think you've done a great job. I
think they do look very, very smart.
Thank you very much indeed, Rosie.
Thank you. Lovely. Excellent.
I feel like the mama peacock,
and these are all my children.
I'm so happy you put that back on!
I think you've got a pretty stable
colour, you know.
You have irregularities there
in the size. A little bit, yeah.
Nice idea, though.
But they really look interesting.
If I saw them in a bakery window,
I'd want to try one. OK.
It is delicious. Oh, thank God.
So, I think your flavours are good.
The proving's good.
The bake's good, the colour's good,
the technique's good.
Flavour's lovely. Yeah, my only
gripe is the size difference.
But nevertheless...
No... Shut up.
PRUE LAUGHS
Well done, Henry. I don't think
you say "shut up" to the judges.
LAUGHTER
Sorry, sorry. No-one's ever told
a handshake to shut up!
That has made my month.
That was good.
I can go now.
I could leave this week
and be happy with that.
I've just achieved a handshake.
I won't wash my hands.
Buzzing that Steph
and Henry have got handshakes.
I don't feel like I've done badly.
I just haven't
done as well as other people.
But it's very unlikely that I'm
going to do well in this Technical.
I'm not holding out
any hope for this,
but let's just have fun anyway.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
NOEL: The bakers were able to
practise their celebratory buns
but have no idea what
Technical mystery lies ahead.
Right, bakers, welcome back.
Time for your Technical challenge.
Today it's been set for you by Paul.
Any words of advice?
This is about the perfect textures
both inside and out.
Thank you for that. Off you pop.
What are they up to today?
They're going to
Paul's soft play area.
Wow, it's a funny thing to call it.
The judges would like you to
make 12 Sicilian cassatelle.
So, cassatelle are typically
served at Carnivale, which is
of course the Italian word for...
Slippers? No. Carnival, yeah.
Oh, yeah. OK.
Your cassatelle are pastry
crescents filled with a smooth
and creamy ricotta, flavoured with
chocolate and orange,
and fried until crispy and golden.
They need to be uniform in shape and
size, perfect for the Carnivale.
Hmm.
You've got an hour and 15.
On your marks...
OPERATIC: # Get set! #
Bake!
ITALIAN ACCENT: Cassatelle.
No, I've never had these before.
Cassatelle. There we go.
Not even the foggiest clue
what it is.
It's what looks like
a pasta machine.
I guess almost like ravioli,
but, like, fried and sweet.
Maybe. I don't know.
Cassatelle.
Basically they're Sicilian snacks
that you'd have at a carnival.
So, inside these beautiful
pastries we've got ricotta,
we've got chocolate and we've got
orange in there as well.
Where the hard bit is, is getting
the pastry nice and thin,
and overall filling this properly
with the ricotta.
Because these look very well filled
and well sealed.
And the other problem
they're going to have is,
obviously you've got to fry it.
If they don't roll their pastry and
it's a bit thick, as soon as it hits
the oil, the chances are
it's going to burst open,
the ricotta will pour out
into the oil.
OK, would you like to try them,
Prue? Yeah.
So, you can see from the inside
it's full of filling.
I don't want to crack into one and
have big air holes in there.
It must have the ricotta chocolate
all the way through. No grittiness.
Nice and orangey. That is delicious.
Great with a cup of tea.
I was thinking it'd be great
with a glass of Marsala.
Well, you would, though,
wouldn't you?
Deep-fat fryer to 170!
This is scaring me, because last
time I had to deal with one of those
I had this weird thing, so I'm just
trying to make this a better memory.
So... "For the dough,
make a stiff, pliable dough."
I don't know what
kind of dough it is that I'm making,
and the ingredients don't
help with it.
Maybe it's more like pasta dough,
which I've never made before, so...
I'm just going to kind of bung it
all in a bowl in some
sort of order and see what happens.
It doesn't say how much water.
I've put a couple of tablespoons
in so far.
"Stiff, pliable." What does it mean?
Not crumbly. A bit of stretch?
I think this is quite pliable now.
So... "Knead until smooth."
Yes!
"Then divide the dough into four."
And that is chilling in the fridge.
I need to sieve the strained ricotta
until smooth and make the filling.
This just takes me back
to Dairy Week.
What are you doing?
I'm trying to get rid of liquid
out of some cheese.
What does it look like I'm doing?
Oh, yeah, of course. Ricotta, right?
Ricotta. Look at that, yeah. Yes.
Can you tell what I'm doing without
looking at a sheet of paper?
Sicilian cassatelle.
And what's that?
I don't know. No!
I wasn't listening when Sandi was
explaining to you what they are!
So, that's a lot of the liquid's now
gone, which is good.
In my head, it was just going,
"La-la-la-la-la-la-la."
I'm going to sieve it.
I've never sieved ricotta.
Ricotta has quite a cheesy,
grainy kind of texture, doesn't it?
So, it might take
a couple of sievings.
No-one ever thought,
"I need to sieve some cheese."
This is the weirdest thing
I've ever done.
Is it meant to do that?
I've put it through the sieve twice,
so it'd better feel smooth now.
So, I'm just going to make the
filling. I've got my sieved ricotta.
Then some orange zest.
Then icing sugar,
and then add some chocolate chips.
I want to make sure
the texture's right as well,
so I don't want any whole
chocolate chips.
It tastes quite nice.
How are you? I'm stressed. What?
You got the old handshake.
I know, but...
Come on, talk me through it.
What did it feel like,
his big sausagey fingers?
What are they like?
Soft but powerful?
Powerful. Powerful. Manicured?
Soft, pampered...
I don't know about manicured. ..but
strong. And then what happened?
When he was
holding your grip like that,
did the tent start spinning
around...
Yeah. ..and Prue levitated up?
HE LAUGHS
Bakers, you are halfway through!
What am I doing? What am I doing?
I like that, cos I think
you took it seriously
and did it with purpose.
Yeah, I think it's about time
we got serious on this show.
"Flatten one ball into
a rough rectangle.
"Feed through a pasta machine."
Going to take a piece of dough.
I have used a pasta machine before
to make pasta, but not pastry.
This is the first time I've used
a pasta machine.
There could be harder things
to use in the world, in fairness.
It's a handle.
Oh, sod it.
Oh, for goodness' sake.
I've made pasta at home once.
It was really good.
I would make it again. Um... Yeah.
CLATTERING
That can happen.
How does one do this?
Oh.
Well, I think we can agree,
this is wrong.
I think mine are quite thick.
Is that too thick? I don't know what
I'm doing. What is going on here?
You can change the settings.
Going up one setting each time,
gradually rolling it thinner,
like I would with pasta.
It's just that I need three hands.
Oh, Sandi's got a hand. What?
Have you got a hand?
Can you crank? You crank. Which way?
Clockwise. Clockwise.
Yeah, that way.
I know what kind of clockwise,
darling!
A bit faster.
My, you're quite bossy.
SHE LAUGHS
Wouldn't be your girlfriend.
THEY LAUGH
"And then cut into rounds. Fill and
seal. Crimp the edges with a fork."
How many are we making? 12, cool.
I need three circles
out of every blob of dough.
See, I feel like that's a bit thick,
maybe.
Fill and seal. Fill and seal.
I've just got to be careful
not to overfill it.
I'm just treating it
like a filled ravioli.
A little bit of water
just to seal the dough.
Because you don't want it to burst
out in the deep-fat fryer.
Oh, we've had leakage.
Too much.
Oh, dear. Too late now, isn't it?
Now it says to fry.
It's a one-word one.
So, we had one other Technical
deep-fat fried. I came last.
This is time to redeem myself, yeah.
Right, these need to go on.
How hot is this?
Don't know how long for yet.
Just going to go in with it.
The pastry's very thin,
so three minutes, flip them.
It's trying to sink, so I'm kind
of holding it. Breathe, Michael.
Just breathe.
I'm just going to try
and look for colour.
I'm guessing it's meant to be
golden brown, isn't it?
Oh, bloody hell,
they puff up, don't they?
NOEL WHISTLES
Jiminy Christmas, look at that guy
having a little splash about
in his Jacuzzi.
One looks all right.
Shall we take it out and see
if it goes crispy?
No, keep it in, keep going.
I don't want to just burn things!
Keep going.
I've got such an adrenaline rush.
You're really sad.
You look done to me.
I'm quite happy.
Do you know, in Whitby, we got the
award for the best fish and chips in
the country one year, so I feel like
I'm doing my town proud as well.
I mean, they don't make cassatelles,
but... I mean, it is crisp.
I am designating this one
as "Looks OK".
Oh, look, it's bursting open.
SHE EXHALES
Nothing I can really do now.
I've not got time for this.
One of mine's burst as well, Alice.
Mine has completely burst, Michael.
Look, one is, like, literally coming
back into a circle again.
I've literally made a taco.
Let's put two more in as well.
I don't want to add any more,
cos that'll lower the temperature
of the vat. I feel like I'm behind,
but I don't know if I am.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes,
15 minutes.
I don't think you're in the shot.
Get a bit closer. Oh, sorry, thanks.
That's better.
15 minutes. These'd better fry
quickly, that's all I can say.
Can we get two scarves next time?
No.
I'm going to bung them all in.
Four there. I've got two here that
are almost done, which makes six.
They are definitely not uniform.
Stay calm.
I'm so far beyond salvage.
A lot of these have decided
to open up.
If I do two at a time for a bit...
Turn that up to the highest it
will go. Come on! Come on!
Far too thick. They're ruined.
Awful.
Just going by eye.
We'll just start getting these out.
Four, six, eight, ten...
12. Look at them.
Desperation stations.
I'm going to
fry them until the very last minute.
Right, bakers!
Take a long time, Sandi,
take a long time.
OK, your time...
..is... ..which is spelt T-I-M-E...
..is...
..is still spelt T-I-ME...
And, erm, you are...
..done!
HE EXHALES
This is a disaster, isn't it?
Please bring your delicious Sicilian
pastries and place them
on the table.
NOEL: Prue and Paul are looking for
12 beautifully filled,
sealed and fried cassatelle.
PRUE: Mmm.
And they'll have no idea
whose is whose.
Now, these are OK.
Fairly uniform and sealed.
PRUE: I think they look lovely.
Let's have a
look at the filling on this.
Could do with a bit more, couldn't
it? Yeah, big air holes in there.
Look. Great flavour.
I think it looks lovely,
tastes lovely.
Could have more of a filling.
But they're a nice shape, and
they're actually well fried as well.
Very good. Moving on to these.
I like the crimping.
But you've lost
a bit on some of them.
That filling is so delicious!
It's really good.
It's got a bit of crispiness to the
shell as well. I like that.
This one's pretty good.
OK, moving on. These haven't been
sealed properly. No.
So, they've just popped open
in the fryer. And puffed up.
Like some kind of seafood creature.
Yeah!
You can see
the big air pocket there.
This is very thick as well
on the pastry.
And too over-fried. Very.
Right. Right, moving on,
similar problem again. Not sealed.
A couple have opened up.
Not much filling in there either.
It's all pastry.
The thinner the pastry,
you would have found it easier
to seal as well.
Now, these are all over-fried.
But they're all sealed.
They're not actually uniform.
They're not all the same shape.
Solid.
Yeah, you can tell straight away...
How thick that is... It's been
cooked all the way through,
but they've had to leave it in
there, cos the pastry's so thick.
But they are all sealed.
This one looks pretty good.
It's nice and light. However...
Same problem. They've burst again.
But they are quite neat,
so it doesn't look too bad.
Oh, and they're quite full, look.
Yeah.
Yeah, a decent amount of filling.
Some nice, thin pastry as well.
OK, this will be interesting.
That'll be number one.
SANDI: Prue and Paul will now rank
the cassatelle from worst to best.
In sixth place, we have this one.
That's me. Alice.
They exploded, didn't they? I know.
Sorry. And very uneven.
Fifth spot, we have this one.
Exploded,
and a little bit soggy as well.
SANDI: Steph is fourth
and Henry is third.
And then, in second place...
..we have this one...
..which is really good, David.
Very nice.
The only thing we found to complain
about at all was that you had
lost the definition of your fork
round the edge.
But otherwise
they were really lovely.
So, in first place, Rosie.
Neat. Nice fork. All sealed
and full of ricotta.
Perfect. Nice.
Yay! I finally won a Technical. Yay.
I've had a bit of a run of fifth.
Fifth, fifth, fifth, fifth,
fifth, fifth, fifth and, yay, first,
so, yeah, super happy.
Second again.
Steph asked me, she was like,
"I think you've got first."
I was like, "No, I repel first.
"I think I've got second."
I knew I hadn't done very well.
I'm not particularly
confident on tomorrow.
Tomorrow's Showstopper is by far
the hardest challenge we've had
to do in the seven weeks.
Not a great end to the day.
It doesn't take a genius
to work out that
I'm kind of sitting
at the bottom, so...
..tomorrow it's going to
be important that I do well.
Oh, it's warm already in here,
isn't it?
Just one challenge remains
before Paul and Prue decide
which bakers
will make it through
to the quarterfinal
and who will be leaving the tent.
So yesterday, I think
I detected a change of atmosphere
in the tent for the better.
You were almost smiling.
Yeah. Almost.
Can I just say, Henry, though,
and his Signature?
Yeah, just say that.
He did really well again.
He told me to shut up. "Shut up!"
Shut up! Shut the door!
I think it was so sweet.
I thought the Signature
was very good.
But to get it done properly,
and it proved it in the technical,
to get it done properly
is quite difficult.
Because of that technical,
we've got Alice and Michael down,
surely, at the bottom.
Alice took a bit of a gamble
and tried to do too much, almost.
She is getting
more and more disorganised.
The benches that are clean means
in their head, they're organised,
and under control. Hers is generally
a crime scene. Yeah.
And David, he has little spells
where he tidies everything up.
David is so good at it.
He keeps everything neat as a pin.
I know, but he's neat as a pin.
Very nice buns.
THEY LAUGH
I never thought I'd hear YOU
say that!
Oh, dear!
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper Challenge.
Today, the judges would like to see
your take on kek lapis Sarawak.
OK, so, this is a colourful cake
which originates from the Sarawak
region of Malaysia.
It's often used in religious
and cultural celebrations.
Your cake should display even
and precise layers,
and be grilled.
Grilled? Grilled.
Wow, the Great British Grill Off.
When your cake is cut
and reassembled,
it should form intricate patterns
that run through it.
You've got four hours
and 15 minutes to do that.
That doesn't sound long enough. No!
On your marks... Get set...
Bake. Or grill.
I'd heard of Malaysia before.
I hadn't heard of Sarawak
or kek or lapis.
In the 1980s, it was very popular
in Indonesia,
and they took it across to Sarawak
in Malaysia,
where they added all the colour.
Imagine Battenberg but more layers.
Do I feel confident? No. Ha!
The Showstopper this week
is a complicated one.
We've asked the bakers to do
a Sarawak-style layer cake.
They have many, many layers
in many different colours
and different flavours.
They put a thin layer of batter
in a cake tin,
grill it for a few minutes,
take it out, more batter, grill it.
However many layers they want.
And then cut it into any shapes
they like.
Then they reassemble those
pieces of cake
so that they make
a fantastic pattern.
It's very difficult to do.
The bakers would never have made
anything like this before.
I think this is one of
the hardest cake designs to make.
And there's nowhere to hide,
we WILL see the problems.
With multiple cakes to make,
each featuring layer upon layer
of sponge...
I have 14 times three eggs,
yes, that number.
..this is one of THE most
complex challenges
ever attempted in the tent.
Waagh! Practising the Showstopper,
I got through 110 eggs in one day.
Hello, Henry. How are you doing,
Henry? Hello! What are you doing?
I am doing a lemon and lime
Sarawak cake.
So how many layers in each cake?
Actually, I've got a drawing
because I can't explain it.
Should hopefully look like that.
Oh, wow, come on.
That's the plan.
Well, that is beautiful.
I'm just going to bring this up
to the table!
It's probably a mistake
to show it to us
because we might be disappointed
if you don't achieve it.
There's a great likelihood of that,
but you might as well know.
Do you know what you should do?
Once the cakes come out,
redraw it
so it looks exactly the same. Yeah.
And pretend you didn't see that.
SANDI: Henry is hoping to bring
his design to life
with contrasting blocks of green
and yellow coloured layer cake,
held together
with raspberry and mint jam,
and flavoured with lime and lemon.
I'm doing six to seven lemons
in each batch.
So if that's not enough lemon zest,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
Not only do Prue and Paul want to
see flawlessly designed cakes...
I'm doing a spice mix
called Spekkoek,
and it's a mixture of cinnamon,
cloves, cardamom and nutmeg.
..they're expecting
our six remaining bakers
to nail their flavours.
I have found that
when you're grilling the cake,
the flavours disappear
more than in a baked cake.
First I was putting various liqueurs
in it.
You couldn't taste a blooming thing.
This is a spiced rum.
I've kind of got into my rums
recently.
So I've googled kek lapises
quite a lot,
and lots of them add,
like, an almond liqueur,
so I thought, well, rum might work.
And we'll see in about four hours
whether it does.
Michael's spiced rum will flavour
his sponge along with ginger
and lime curd.
And he's hoping to colour
and decorate his cake
with green, yellow and black,
to represent
Jamaica's national flag.
So, how many layers altogether?
I do six layers on each cake. Yeah.
So it should be 6 x 4. Yeah.
24. 24? Well done. Thank you.
THEY LAUGH
How tentatively we all... "24...?"
Michael's not the only baker
who's hitting the bottle.
Orange liqueur is going into it,
which is my step-grandma's
favourite drink.
I remember her drinking it and me
drinking half of hers every time.
So I've got to get a bit of her
in this.
Steph's using her step-gran
Sheila's favourite tipple
to make an orange liqueur syrup
that will hold together
her orange and chai spiced
layered sponge squares.
I was trying to go triangles,
but they were particularly hard
to manipulate
so I've reverted back to lines.
We've all tried to do triangles,
but triangles don't work.
But with her design, Rosie is going
where no other baker has dared.
I've got two eight-layer cakes,
and they will be cut into
a square cross-section,
then halved into a triangle, then
halved again into another triangle.
And then reassembled into
sort of a diamond-y pattern.
I'm probably taking on too much
but I do that every single time,
so I don't learn.
Topped with her second delicate
bird decoration this week,
Rosie's ambitious
triangular-patterned cake
will be made up of multicoloured
layers of lemon
and mixed spice sponge.
It's a balancing act
because it either looks beautiful
but it's like eggy rubber...
Eggy rubber!
Literally the first one I made,
you could do that
with the whole thing...
That's a good name for a band.
If I form a band called
Eggy Rubber, will you be in?
I'll sing,
you play drums and guitar.
I don't think I want to be known
as Eggy Rubber.
Come on, me and you, Eggy Rubber.
Like the new Simon and Garfunkel
but a bit more electronic.
I'll book us some gigs
in all the festivals.
Oh! We're supporting Radiohead,
Eggy Rubber.
As well as
perfectly flavoured sponge,
getting the colours of the cake
layers right is just as crucial.
You can't do a dull one.
I mean, the whole point is
they are really garish, bright,
over-the-top colours.
I'm going for pink,
green and yellow.
That's lovely! Do you like it?
Well, see, pink, that's not what I
thought pink tasted like, delicious.
Oh, good. I'll come back
and clean the bowl for you.
Excellent. Do you want some of this
as well? You don't need that.
I'll get that. Thank you. Prue?
One of my cakes is just two colours.
The other ones are going to be
four different colours.
You've got to be careful because you
want to get the colour throughout
but you want to mix as minimum
as possible.
David's contrasting monochrome
and multicoloured cakes
will be flavoured with a traditional
Indonesian spice mix,
brushed with tamarind and honey,
and formed into what
he hopes will be
a post-modernist work of art.
So I wanted mine
to be more like a sculpture.
I just love all these colours.
These ones are actually based on
a Prue Leith necklace
from last season.
I don't believe you.
Doesn't surprise me. It is!
And I'm doing one black-and-white
cake and one with these colours.
Does that represent me?
I like it already.
The grey. I mean, it did...
Prue, there's Noel, and there's me.
We can go with that.
Wow, I'm wallpaper paste.
This is the nerve-racking bit.
Just, like, a really thin spread.
This is quite scary,
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
"I'm not going to have enough."
Hello, Alice. Morning.
How are you? Sarawak layer cake,
what are you doing?
Yes, so festivals, I am doing
a kind of carnival Sarawak cake.
So every year in my hometown
we have a carnival
and at the end of that
is a big fireworks display.
What's your hometown?
Burnham-on-Crouch in Essex.
Essex, are you an Essex girl?
I am an Essex girl, yes.
You don't seem like an Essex girl.
Why? What are you trying to say?
Do you want a spade? Huh?
I think
you could stop right there.
Let's come in again, yeah?
SANDI: Alice's homage to her
hometown festival
will have sugar work fireworks
exploding out of a chocolate, orange
and salted caramel cake, in a
kaleidoscope of coloured layers.
Is this the first one you're going
to build now? Yeah, the first one.
Always scares me, it looks so thin
but then it does puff up
a little bit.
How long are you going
to grill it for?
You have to be quite careful,
just a couple of minutes, I think,
because it's still very thin.
Fantastic, good luck.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. I'll be here layering.
Right.
I'm going into the oven.
My tins don't fit. Come on...
Yes, yes, they do!
With multiple cakes to make...
Right, I'm going in finally.
..and each one featuring
numerous layers of batter,
grilling must be meticulous.
Don't look, don't look!
But the intense direct heat
can be tricky to control.
I'll try not to be scared,
it's just I don't know
what temperature to have it at.
If they are over-grilled, the sponge
layers will be rubbery and tough.
So, we're just winging it
at the moment.
But under-cooking will cause
the layers to collapse.
I think that's done.
Not good.
Ow! Hot.
I don't have enough cake mix.
I mean, yeah.
It's a bit of a problem.
I don't want to wreck
any more layers
because I kind of need
all my mixture.
So I'm going to have half a cake
at this point, I think.
HOOTER HONKS
Bakers, you're halfway through.
Halfway through. Fun!
FEEBLE HONKING
Hope it's all right inside.
Too late now.
This is layer two...
..of 3,002.
I'm going to brush a tiny wee bit
of rum onto every third layer.
I don't want to put too much in
otherwise it will go wet.
I'm weighing out the layers
so that they're all the same weight
and therefore depth.
So each layer needs to be identical
for that pattern to work.
I think it's going OK,
but until it's out of the tin
you don't know how it's done anyway.
I've got four more layers left
on this cake.
Right. Next one.
Not only do the bakers need to
keep an eye on the grill...
I burnt the first layers. You can
see the remnants in the sink.
Oh, jam.
..they have to make their
fillings...
I'm making the lime curd,
which is going to be
the glue that holds
my cake together.
..whilst also preparing
their decorations.
This is just like blowing glass.
It sets really quite quickly.
That may be OK.
I'm just making my marzipan.
Have like a bonfire,
carnival, fireworks.
I don't know how Alice
produces such good things
when there's stuff everywhere.
Nice and tidy around here as usual.
You don't look silly at all.
If that drops on any of the eggs...
Oooh! My g...
We can do this.
I can only move my eyes.
I feel like a painting
in the background.
You know where the eyes follow you
around the room? Mm.
Are you listening to me?
I... I am...
On a scale of 1 to 10,
how much do you enjoy our chats?
11. Yes!
Burning, burning, burning, burning.
There's definitely burning going on.
Something is burning. I'm not,
I'm not burning. Who's burning?
What?
It's only had two minutes.
There's nothing I can do with that.
No, I'm going to bin that.
But all my layers will have to be
thinner now.
SHE GROANS
Right, my lovely Sarawak people.
You've got one hour left.
Whilst Rosie has to start
her last cake all over again...
I don't understand what happened.
I need to watch it really,
really closely. I'm stopping now.
..the others have finally finished
with their grills
and are about to find out if their
layer cakes have been a success.
Yes! It's not raw, it's not raw!
I'm happy enough with that.
Definitely more rubbery
than I was hoping.
Like, that's a rainbow, I think.
It's just the chopping up
that creeps me out
because if you do it wrong,
that's it. Game over.
If they don't cut and shape
their cakes with accuracy...
3.5cm.
..and precision...
You want a really sharp knife
for cutting this cake.
..their intricate pattern designs
won't work.
This is my little cutting guide.
My dad made it.
I told him the measurements
in a bit of a panic, saying,
"I can't cut these things," so my
dad made me one, I'm really lucky.
This is a bread-slicer.
So you can do perfect slices.
It's all about the visual now,
I need to get it right.
Trying to remember
how I do my patterns now.
I want them to go together.
It's not perfect at all
but it will have to do.
Considering how little cake
I've got, I'm wasting quite a lot.
Do you think it's a little small?
No, I think that's all you want
to eat of this sweet, rubbery...
Wow, not really selling
grilled cake to me. No. No.
Nearly a drop.
Triangles are stressful.
It's really, really hard.
Bakers!
You have 15 minutes remaining.
Crack on.
HE WHISTLES CHEERFULLY
I've got a cake, I've got a cake,
I've got a cake.
I just need to get it decorated.
Quarter of an hour is not really
enough time to finish
but I'm gonna have something.
Forgot to put lime curd on it
before I lifted up the marzipan
like an idiot. It is what it is.
SHE SIGHS
It's messy but it's on.
Mine's so much smaller
than everyone else's.
Not going to be anywhere
near as neat as when I practised.
That is always very gutting.
If I was in the trenches, I'd say
I'd lost a leg but I'm not dead.
This is just not fun, you know.
There's a small chance of
a full recovery, perhaps.
Struggling a bit
but I'm still going.
Right, bakers. Time is up.
Please place your kek lapis Sarawak
at the end of your work stations.
Well, it's something, isn't it?
It's done.
Well done, kids. Well done,
everybody. That was a long one.
Could have gone worse.
Come here, darling.
THEY GROAN
The bakers' Sarawak-style layer
cakes
now face the judgment of Paul and
Prue.
Steph, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
The blocks that you've rotated
needed more filling in between
because there's big gaps there,
which shouldn't be there.
You almost want to grout round it
and just make it neater, you know?
Yeah. I agree about the little gaps,
but the pattern is very Sarawakian
and I think it looks lovely.
The sponges are delicious as well.
They're very good. They're soft.
I have to tell you, the marzipan is
brilliant. Just delicious.
The decoration's good as well.
I think you've done a good job.
Very good, Steph.
Thank you, Steph. Thank you.
I think it looks a bit messy. Yeah.
It's not neat at all.
You can see the colours,
they're vibrant enough,
but I just want to see what
it's like inside when we cut in.
That is a very complicated
pattern to attempt.
That's got quite a toasty flavour,
that. What is the jam inside?
It's nectarine jam. You can't
identify it. You know it's there.
Gives it a little zing.
It's very nice, the taste.
The idea's sound enough,
it just hasn't been executed to
a better level to really shine off
what you've actually done,
cos there's a lot of work there.
It's a shame you didn't add a little
bit more colour into the top
and bottom layers because that
bottom layer there looks
quite raw and rubbery.
I drizzled rum between the layers
so it has got a bit of moisture
in it. Oh, did you? Yeah.
There are layers, but
because they're all the same colour
or almost exactly the same colour,
it looks just like one solid slab.
It is a little stodgy.
Very claggy,
very stodgy in the mouth.
I think the soaking was
probably a bad idea.
It's almost like all one now
and a very dense piece
so when you eat it, it's a
bit rubbery.
Overall, it looks wonderful, it's
just a pity about the texture. OK.
Thanks, Michael. Thank you, Michael.
WHISPERS: It's all right, it's fine.
What's this? Just cake. Oh, the
cake. There's a lot of cake there.
It's all cake. It's all cake? Yeah.
Well, I think that's really clever.
Looks like a stack of egg sandwiches
at an afternoon tea. Yeah.
That's what I was going for. Is that
what you were going for? Yeah.
Shut up!
LAUGHTER
Henry, I think that is
a really nice-textured cake.
It's not stodgy, the lemon and lime
comes through. It's really nice.
Actually, I'm quite impressed.
It's not perfect... No. ..but it's
been executed pretty well and,
actually, you do get a nice flavour
in the mouth and nice texture.
Certainly not rubbery.
It breaks apart like a cake would,
even though
it's cut into
so many different pieces.
I actually think you've done
a pretty good job.
Well, I tell you, my first
impression is that it's
architecturally very interesting.
I love the shape of it.
My next is that it's very small.
I mean, this was supposed to be for
a party -
a big cake for a lot of people.
Is this for Sandi's family?
The Sylvanians still
have to eat, you know!
There was meant to be more, but I
had an issue with some of my layers.
I lost quite a bit.
The lines that you've
managed to achieve
and the colour definitions that
you've got here are pretty good.
Nice and spicy. I think
it could be a bit sweeter, really.
It's a little bit rubbery.
It's perfectly edible
if you had a piece like this,
you couldn't eat much more than
that, but I quite like the favour.
I love the neatness of it.
I think it's very neat.
I just think the whole thing is not
quite sweet enough.
If you eat a tiny little bit of
icing with it, it's great.
I think it's extremely neat.
The detail in it is incredible, the
way you've gone to all this trouble
to get this pattern going, and then
the lines on the top are beautiful.
The painting, the decorations
of the fireworks look good.
It looks a bit dry and that's
my only concern at the moment.
The layers are so thin
and they're so small,
your little blocks or strips, that
it almost looks like weaving.
That is pretty clever, isn't it?
That is very, very good.
And the almond in there as well?
Yeah. Tastes like marzipan. Mm.
That works really well.
The marzipan gives it that petit
four almost texture flavour
in your mouth.
I think the detail in there is
exceptional, it's fine, vibrant.
Very artistic. Very good.
I think it really works. Well done.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you. Well done.
Phew!
I mean, you never know,
I did lose Technical...
My buns weren't amazing, but I think
I might just have saved myself.
If I got Star Baker, it'd be nice
cos that's the final, like,
tick list of being...
It would be a lovely little
bonus to get that.
Paul did tell me to shut up,
though, he got me back,
cos I told him to shut up in the
Signature, so... fair play.
I was going to say I got a grilling,
but I tried to hold that one in.
Did all right in the Signature,
just wasn't as good.
Didn't do well in the Technical -
surprise! - and I've done OK
in the Showstopper,
but now OK isn't enough.
Myself, Alice, Michael
and Rosie have all had positives
and negatives. Anyone could go.
I could go this week.
It's really, really close, I think.
That was pretty good.
I thought it was fantastic.
Rosie's was a bit messy.
I think she put herself down into a
spot of trouble.
She was so ambitious.
I mean, the way she cut her cakes
was much more complicated
and difficult, and she didn't
succeed. It's a pity.
Thought Michael's was quite neat,
but you weren't as impressed with it
were you?
Michael's chief problem was
there were lots of layers
in there and they all run together
cos they're squished, aren't they?
Blends in with the marzipan,
doesn't it?
I think, point in question,
is when you look at David's,
look how neat that is. Yeah.
It's a shame they were very small
and they were a bit rubbery.
I liked the decoration with cake
on cake that Henry did.
Oh, I loved it.
The taste of Henry's was very good.
You've got that lime and lemon,
perfect combination,
the colours balanced up beautifully.
As was Steph's. I mean, she had a
problem with the filler on that one,
but you can see every single line,
every single colour in there as
well.
I think Alice has done a great
job on this challenge, actually.
She was in terrible trouble
coming into the Showstopper. Yeah.
She must have saved herself, surely.
That was such a good cake.
Who might be in line for Star Baker?
For me, I think Rosie and Michael
are in a little bit of trouble.
I think Alice has saved herself
and I think any one of the other
three could be Star Baker
and that includes Henry, Steph...
possibly David.
Hello, bakers.
I've got the fantastic job of
announcing who's won Star Baker.
And the person who's won
Star Baker this week is...
..Henry.
"Shut up!"
So this leaves me with the horrible
job and it gets so hard now.
I'm afraid the person who is
leaving us is...
..Michael.
I'm so sorry. It's OK, it's OK.
It was my time. It's OK.
I feel OK.
My head is held high and I am so
happy and so proud...
..and so tired!
I'm going out laughing,
and that's brilliant.
It's totally fine, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I wish I was a pretty crier,
you know, like in black and white
French films when it's raining.
Instead I'm, like, crying cos I
couldn't make a Kek lapis that well.
PAUL: It's pretty sad, Michael
going.
He did OK, but, overall, the
standard this week has got better
and I think from now on in,
we're going to see a different
standard of baking.
Ha, well...
..that's my tick list now.
Don't need to do any more.
I've ticked everything off.
Alice has made me cry now.
Oh, no!
I'm just gutted, erm...
that Michael has left, yeah.
He's just been so supportive.
I don't think I'd have got this far,
to be honest, without Michael.
I'm so glad to be going through.
I can't quite believe it.
I think it's going to take a
while to sink in,
kind of... week eight of the
Bake Off.
SANDI: Next time...
..it's the quarterfinals...
Ooh... ..and Pastry Week.
Never had a massive penchant for a
pie.
The bakers face a savoury
Signature Bake...
Over under, over, under.
..which turns everything on its
head...
Hot damn!
..a brush-off in the Technical...
Ugh.
..and a towering Showstopper...
It's the pie of shame.
..which could leave their semifinal
dreams...
Oh, for God's sake!
..as just pie in the sky.
It's like a shark,
but with even less mercy.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media